more closed-door testimony is scheduled
today in the house impeachment inquiry
on Capitol Hill one whistleblower you'll
recall accused President Trump of
pushing Ukraine to investigate the
Biden's in exchange for military aid
while the law firm representing the
whistleblower is fighting to keep their
clients identity a secret this is
despite calls from the president and
other Republicans to reveal it CBS News
special correspondent and co-host of
Showtime's the circus that's Alex Wagner
spoke with an attorney at the law firm
since news broke about a whistleblower
complaint deemed credible and urgent by
the Inspector General of the
intelligence community president Trump
has appeared to focus on unmasking his
or her identity I think a whistleblower
should be protected if the
whistleblowers legitimate but among the
layers of protection for whistleblowers
to a certain degree is anonymity is
there whistleblower afforded a federal
protection if they are unmasked it's not
quite clear what would necessarily be
legally entitled with respect to this
whistleblower who gets to make that
decision
in theory the president bradley moss is
from the law firm mark saeed which is
representing the whistleblower at the
route of the impeachment inquiry is it a
fool's errand to think that this person
is gonna stay anonymous if this person
becomes the story and the subject of all
this is not about whether or not the
president's you know behavior is conduct
was wrong and picha but whatever you
want to describe it as it becomes about
the bias of the whistleblowers but the
president's allies on Capitol Hill see
that issue differently the American
people have a right to know who started
this whole thing
this week Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan who sits on one of the
committee's conducting the closed-door
impeachment depositions demanded
transparency you've called for this
person to be unmasked do you worry that
harm may come to him or her if he or she
is unmet we don't we don't well the
president's rhetoric on this no we don't
want harm on anyone
but what I do know and what I do worry
about is the idea that you have someone
who is anonymous who has no first-hand
knowledge and who has a bias against the
president today the house is preparing
for more high profile depositions you
think the information that has come out
since this initial whistleblower report
was made public has buttress the
whistleblowers complaint or negated it I
think it is what it is
it's the transcript and the two most
important people on this whole issue are
President Trump and Ukraine president
szalinski they both said there was no
quid pro quo hey Alex Wagner is on
Capitol Hill good morning Alex so Adam
Schiff says he's keeping these
transcripts secret for now but
eventually we'll release them
what's his case for doing this behind
closed doors so House Democrats say look
this is a fact-finding mission and it's
important that we get at the truth and
as such we can't have witnesses
coordinating their stories with one
another so these proceedings need to
happen behind closed doors they further
say that Democrats and Republicans in
the committees are getting equal time so
this is a fair proceeding that has not
convinced House Republicans who are
lashing out at Adam Schiff and Democrats
saying this is a secret soviet-style set
of hearings Alex the ambassador to the
European Union Gordon Sunland goes
before lawmakers today why is his
testimony so important Salman is a big
deal today on the hill he is the
ambassador to the European Union and has
been intimately involved in the back and
forth between the Trump White House and
president Solinsky House Democrats are
particularly interested in meetings that
somnolent had in the White House with
Ukrainian officials and they are likely
to ask about a series of text messages
he was directed to send by the order of
President Trump himself there is a lot
that will happen behind closed doors
today you can expect that testimony is
going to go on for quite sometime today
it's gonna be really interesting when he
justifies there's been so much
conflicting information revolving around
him but let's talk about the impeachment
vote Alex where did the Democrats stand
on that you know they're surprising
unanimity from both sides of the aisle
here widespread expectation that the
Democrats are going to proceed forward
with articles in impeachment in a sort
of
expeditious manner if you will Mitch
McConnell the Senate leader yesterday
said that he expects to receive articles
of impeachment from Nancy Pelosi around
Thanksgiving and that the Senate will
move forward with an impeachment trial
that he expects to wrap before the end
of the year so bipartisan Accord that
this should be happen happening
relatively quickly given all the
testimony that we've had thus far and
testimony that we have yet to hear and
that it will happen before the end of
the year all right Alex Wagner thanks
Alex
the circus airs Sundays on Showtime a
division of CBS check your local
listings